The Department of Homeland Security is looking
to increase it's monitoring
of Facebook and Twitter.
Something like Palantir is the key to stopping
major terrorist attacks.
These are profile based, automated precrime
suspicion generating mechanisms.
Precogs see the future and they're never wrong.
I would compare artificial intelligence and
machine learning to the advent of electricity.
It looks to us like a black box.
The intelligence community is focused on getting
intelligence wherever it can
by any means possible.
You're just told 'Sorry, you can't go there.
You can't do that.'
We all leave digital trails behind us as we
journey through the world.
And rapid advancements in artificial intelligence
and machine learning technology
have allowed corporations and governments
to build ever more precise tools
to analyse that data,
discover patterns, and even predict behavior.
I think one of the things that we're in the
process of grappling with as a society
is what does this technology mean?
What does it do?
I would compare artificial intelligence and
machine learning to the advent of electricity.
So imagine that you just heard about this
magical thing called electricity
look there are bad things you could do with
electricity,
you could put people in an electric chair
and use it for capitol punishment.
Those are things we have to work through with
this technologies,
what are those concerns?
Some privacy experts, however, worry that
handing this powerful technology
over to opaque government agencies is laying
the groundwork for a total police state.
The Berlin wall wasn't actually built in a
day, it was built quickly.
But the checkpoints already existed, it's
just that people were accustomed
to passing from the American zone to the Soviet
zone to the French zone
and what changed on the day was that all of
a sudden the turnstile didn't lift
you weren't allowed through the checkpoint.
Then the wall was built then.
But in building the checkpoints, in building
the control mechanisms
we're already putting in place the infrastructure
for those who will abuse them in future.
Some Silicon Valley companies
have been building artificially intelligent
surveillance tools for the deep state
that help government agents make sense of
massive amounts of information
scattered across several databases
and to discover patterns that might otherwise
be hidden.
They're called threat intelligence firms
and one of the biggest in the business is
named Palantir.
One of the ways that people use threat intelligence
is in terms of open source intelligence.
Gathering information about national security
or other threats
just by, essentially, reading the news, reading
twitter.
Companies like Palantir can run artificial
intelligences
that can read a lot more of twitter
than any one person or even a team of people
could possibly think of doing.
Palantir recieved an early 2 million dollar
investment from INQTEL
the venture capital arm of the CIA.
But Palantir's biggest early funder
was Paypal founder, Facebook board member,
and Trump supporter Peter Thiel.
Who invested 30 million dollars in the company
which now has a 20 billion dollar valuation.
Something like Palantir is the key to stopping
major terrorist attacks.
I don't think we're gonna do it by projecting
military force throughout the world
we will do it by uncovering these conspiracies
before they come together.
The United States has conducted an operation
that killed Osama bin Laden
the leader of Al Qaeda.
Journalist Mark Bowden reported in 2012 that
the hunt for bin Laden
drew on an unfathomably rich database.
And after the government failed to parse the
data on it's own
Palantir developed a product that actually
deserves the popular designation Killer App.
And Thiel, an outspoken Libertarian, told
Fortune Magazine
he hopes this technology will actually help
protect the civil liberties of Americans.
Because, given the massive amounts of American's
data the government takes in
"If we could help them make sense of data,
they could end indiscriminate surveillance."
We're not creating a technology that's this
black box algorithmic engine
that you just throw data into it and it spits
out an answer to you.
But privacy experts worry that the secrecy
around some of Palantir's contracts
with the Department of Homeland Security are
eroding civil liberties.
Palantir's tools, in their sophistication
and complexity
and their algorithmic rule set,
enable the transition from this watching role
to a proactive predictive policing role.
They are the supposed precogs.
Precogs see the future and they're never wrong.
But it's not the future if you stop it, isn't
that a fundamental paradox?
The movie Minority Report famously portrayed
a society
where police harness the power of psychic
precogs
to arrest people for crimes before they are
ever actually committed.
A 2012 Department of Homeland Security report
boasts that Palantir's tech
'can be used to predict future activities.'
So in moving down that path of precrime profiling
we're accepting that it is legitimate to impose
consequences
based on robotic precog's conclusions about
what you're likely to do in the future.
So we say artificial intelligence
and we think about Skynet and HAL from 2001.
A lot of times the actual technical reality
is much more mundane and less exciting.
We may be looking at things that are,
for the AI simply understanding what humans
may intuitively get,
if you drop a pen on the floor, you're likely
to bend over and pick it up,
or types of predictions that might be in the
aggregate, right?
So for an aggregate population that undertakes
certain behaviors
some percentage of them are likely to do X
Y or Z.
The time is overdue to develop a new screening
test for the threats we face today.
I call it extreme vetting.
When the Trump administration talks about
extreme vetting
they, Palantir's tools and the decisions based
on them are what they're talking about.
Palantir landed a major government contract
in 2014
when the Obama administration approved a 41.6
million dollar deal
with Immigration and Customs Enforcement to
set up an algorithmic profiling system.
How many government contracts do you currently
hold today.
Most of our contracts have massive clauses
in them saying we can't disclose.
The full extent of Palantir's federal contracts
remains unknown
but under the Trump administration
the company has created a profiling system
for Border Patrol
and a former Palantir lobbyist serves in the
Pentagon
as Deputy Chief of Staff to Defense Secretary
James Mattis.
Representatives from Palantir declined to
participate in this video
but the company website assures visitors that
there is oversight
from Palantir's Council on Privacy and Civil
Liberties.
Palantir is as opaque today as they were when
they were founded.
When other organizations have filed FOIA requests
seeking information about it
they're almost uniformly denied.
It looks to us like a black box and without
being inside Palantir
it's hard to say exactly how it works.
The Department of Homeland Security
has only released highly redacted materials
about these systems
arguing in court that the algorithms must
stay secret in order to remain effective.
One of the challenges in a lot of intelligence
work is that oftentimes
the nature of the work is that if you explain
publicly exactly what you're doing
and how you're collecting information on,
whether it's a terrorist or another government
you spoil that source of information.
When the government is telling judges, whose
role is to review and prove these things
'trust us but don't actually look at what
we're doing, don't look behind the curtain.'
that should be a red flag that something wrong
is going on behind the curtain
and we need to look more closely at it.
Enemies of freedom committed an act of war
against our country.
What we've seen since 9/11
is the emergence of a homeland security industrial
complex
that now rivals in it's lobbying power and
it's influence in Washington ,
the military industrial complex.
But I think the existence of a homeland security
industrial complex
as a force in Washinton regardless of which
party is in power
has been largely unrecognized.
Because of the secrecy around the technology,
it's hard to know to what degree the federal
government has deployed it
not only against immigrants and refugees,
but against American citizens.
We do know, post 9/11, that information sharing
between foreign intelligence agencies
and domestic law enforcement has become routine.
Once these tools are built, the mission creep
is extremely rapid.
Once the NSA builds a tool to try and find
terrorists' phone calls
it was almost immediately used by DEA to find
street level drug criminals.
If ICE builds a tool using Palantir technology
we can be certain that that tool will be used
to whatever government customer wants to do.
The real question is what do we do with the
technology?
Right?
Who's using it, for what purposes and under
what kinds of safeguards?
Particularly when we're talking with the government,
what are the checks and balances in place?
But there's no technology that is just inherently
good or inherently bad.
It's about how we're using it and to what
ends.
I don't think that it's inevitable
that the government is going to adopt this
kind of technology
anymore than it's inevitable that we're going
to have a regime
where you have to show your papers everywhere
you go
or where there are virtual checkpoints everywhere
and your facial image and it's template is
a virtual key
that's vetted every time you walk down the
street.
The situation is bad, it's going to take significant
change
and significant popular resistance and push
back.